Ok take idi.
Tuesday you think they have them
in on in only two in lismore
and speaking with barry.
Back. My name is barry
barry and jerome barry.
Been working out in nimbin for the
last three years in an informal manner
and formally for the last four
months being arcs by the elders
and endorsed by the elders to get
certain projects happening in their own
and particular bunch along language and.
Community activities within
them. But in the culture.
They have if i just city.
Were. One thing come from nimble that.
Comes from my word nimble which is
the hairy people of the country.
And prior to
that anybody who was a area a grey haired
woman. A very wise man was there.
They come from what i hear people have
always been here in this country from time
immemorial. And they were here
when the bagel first arrived.
That's the dark skin people
were talking about bagel.
And they landed at eventide there
was another landing also at the.
No
but this particular one it evans
had the bagel landed there
and then began the process of
settlement within this country
and they came across the
nimbin people at blue knob.
That ninian which was a holy place
and then when the jags call sacred.
And a war then erupted between the nimbin.
People and the bagel.
And during that war the bagel people
were pushed back down to the coast.
And tradition was then formed.
Whereas the children of
the bagel who had certain
leanings towards healing were
taken to nimbin. And were then.
Shown the healing sciences
and medicinal herbal usage
and sacred law
and they were then taken back down to their
people. The battle to instruct them.
In the internal
that was always a place of
spirituality and of healing.
Yeah yeah. From them. It tells about
the. People what were they like.
Oh very gentle people
they were vegetarian.
People they had orange hair.
And like i said they'd
been here for a long time.
Their places underground
places their sacred places of
crystals of.
Metals of healing places and power
places they were taught by the name
but what was significance.
In the role there was learnings
within the rocks themselves on things
that were to pass
that i still say never because it's
sort of like a movie projector.
I mean i can sit down and
and look at global ghali which is
a big the big rock the first one
that scene from lismore and.
There's etchings there sculptures there's
oil paintings is photographs there's it's
a lack of a movie you can sit there and
just watch a movie. If you say like.
From sunup to sundown.
And you can see faces
figures there are animals
that are definitely european
and if i can see those things
and i'm not the only one who have seen
things in the rock they're not a loose
notions because they're
created by natural causes.
By light and shade and by
texture. And so on and so on.
So they're not loose nations. You know.
And you know they're not under any
mushrooms or or anything like that.
You know this seed with the weather
with a clear bright clear eyes.
And if i could see those things
in the rock. I know for sure.
And as a fact that the old people
also saw what was in those rocks
and it was no surprise to them when the
european people came into the country
but they recognized their
faces and their animals.
So some people say that we.
When it's clay in the process.
Can you tell us all while
nimbin for a start.
Wasn't the place where people went
out there to settle full time.
While none of the old people did anyway.
They were always in a state of movement.
Moving around the country. You
know it was pretty boring.
To stay in one place you know sort
of it wasn't buying a half acre.
And having the pay off the
bank. Well if you lie for it.
You know everyone was free to go and
move where they want to and the fact
that nimbin was is that people went
out there for specific purposes
and it may take two years it may take
three years for whatever purpose
that was needed for them in their development
of exploration within themselves you
know of human power or human abilities.
Not so much power but you
mean abilities and knowledge
and like i said they could happen.
You know six months it
could happen in two years
and three years could happen in four
years but you know then you moved on.
There were other places to explore there
were other places to get knowledge from.
And there were places out
there within the area where.
Where the women didn't go and not
because that they were exempt from
that place is because of
the ability of the women
and their sensitivity to be
able to receive this knowledge
and the power of these
places from a distance
that there was no need for them to
go inside them or to go up to them.
That was the men's business in that act
of penetration or of confrontation.
The women had no need for that they
receive their full part and see
and power from a distance because that's
their nature. That's their. That's it.
Every so tells a bit about the children of
the victim or the way. The bagel.
The children of the baby or whether
with the way they were given the title.
We and by the nimble.
What with their role to heal
and to teach a good law to the bagel.
Which is the knowledge of
the earth that sacred law
and the bagel knew the law they knew
the stars they came from the sea.
They were quite familiar with
stars and with the sky dreams.
But the sacred law in this
country is knowledge of the land
that sacred also in the
cygnus country. Can you.
Well it's certainly a country as a country
where you go to to get rid of your
sickness.
And that's anywhere in the country where
certain there is a designated sickness
country that's not a place
where you go and get sick.
It's a place where you take a sickness
to get rid of it because there are areas
within that country that
have that power to take
that sickness from you
anticipate it through.
The land because at that you think.
Through tracks people. Something
you have to heal yourself.
Oh yeah there's a heavy
sicknesses out there
and women at the moment you know
there's big. Drug abuse problems.
I'm talking my drug abuse
on the tournament drugs.
People are entitled to
use drugs if they wish.
With proper knowledge but if you don't
have a proper knowledge of drugs
when you just drug abuse and so there's
drug abuse going on at the moment.
That's because of the draconian methods
of the government and the state laws
that people. Getting sicker and sicker.
Because of a social law does not because
of the law of the land the land is ailing
all the time but if you have a
social situation where a plant.
Naturally growing plant
from a seed is outlawed
and made illegal and it's
the base of heroin trade
and criminal activities within them
and the law has to be changed.
That's a social law
and it's killing the people the laws of
this land are killing the people of the
land.
Back to the way you know.
The sickness.
That that. You.
So i've got what we have to i think what
we have to get dna to tim is the people's
ability to look for a culture.
People's ability to come in
contact and to learn a culture
that has laws
and this is a problem that's been
in this country for a long time is
that there are people who have come from
european descent who find it very hard
to come to terms with certain laws.
Now there were say in nimbin for instance
there are people who are interested in
bunge island. Culture.
They're interested in finding out what
the old people did prior to invasion.
The condition
that was here in the country prior to
invasion was vastly different to the
condition that has been in this
country for the last 200 years.
Now that's with so-called tribal
law the law in this country
had to be strict.
Any civilization that's under attack
or invasion tighten up their
laws they introduce martial law.
So this country has been in the sense under
a form of martial law for the last 200
years and so some people take it as
being that this is aboriginal culture
that these are the laws
of the aboriginal people.
Yeah they are of course the laws of the
aboriginal people but they are the laws
that weren't there not the laws that we
here 200 years ago prior to 200 years.
They were different. There was
no need for a lot of the laws
that are now within aboriginal
society or culture but even so
that there are still people
who have no wish for. Laws.
You know. Some women were told
of by the elders or by people
that women aren't supposed
to go up to the rocks.
What do you get you get groups
of women going up to the rocks.
Or the elders say. You can't go there
and what do you know before you
know it you've got picnic this
and you've got people on my she's going to
those places because basically they were
told not to go there. So this is a state
of lawlessness people have told the law
and for very good reason.
And so people deliberately go out
of the way to go and break the law.
So if people are going
to have that attitude.
There's a lot of the elders are
not happy with that attitude
that if they tell people something about.
Culture
and about the laws of the land because
it is a laws from the land the law comes
from the land doesn't come from the
people is transmitted by the people.
So if you know the land.
The laws of the land are told to people and
the people don't wish to have any any.
Respect for that while they just lose
respect in the eyes of the elders at all.
And so they are you find a situation where
the elders just wont talk about any such
thing because they can see
that these people are really
not interested in law at all.
They're not really interested in culture.
They're basically just interested
in power. If people break the laws.
Some people said to me.
Well people curse themselves by
neglecting and by disregarding the laws
that were given by the elders anyway.
You know that curse doesn't come from the
elders or from the old people at all.
They certainly didn't go around cursing
people you know people have respect there's
no need to curse. It's only when
those people have disrespect
that they curse themselves.
You know it's personal responsibility
we're talking about here
and that's a very strong mainstay
within the career culture is personal
responsibility for your actions
and if you don't have a responsibility
for your actions when your curst you do
that to yourself no one else.
No one else is to blame for that
you know the land has its laws
and if you wish to transgress those
laws or do this. Disregard them.
While your cursing yourself. That's all.
You know it's paid its people its
people have disregard the laws
that are cursing themselves
with poison water.
You know the disk the cursing themselves
with with heat from the cutting down of
the rainforest the cursing themselves with
putting cattle on the cursing themselves
with the poisons in their foods
that cursing themselves out
people not cursing them for that.
You. Yes.
This story.
Well the rainbow serpent is
like other snake yelling
and yelling back and. That's a
place of the rainbow serpent.
And or the carpet snake the
bath one in the same and.
That was a very strong center for the
brain by snake dreaming in the membrane
valley its crystals.
Because if they could rambus
like the crystal in the moon.
So that was another place where
like i said with a healing.
For all forms of healing that comes
under the demesne of carpets
and of rainbow snake
or the things you telling me
stories. Nothing's changed. No no.
They can change the
dreamings can be added to.
Basically the story remains the same.
But they can be added to they can be given
another perspective because there are so
many you've got 360 360 degrees.
And you can take any one of those paths.
But whatever path you take
there's a dreaming story for
that because the old people had gone.
On
that path some time people throughout the
histories of this country people have been
there. They've been there
and have done that.
So nothing's really changed in this country
as far as i goes because no matter
where you go in this country.
It's been walked before someone
had been along that same track
that you're following.
So in other words there's always been
someone ahead of you who has been there.
So you're just following their
track. No matter where you go.
And i'm not just talking about like
human form but a good homosapien form.
You know in a totem way you
know totem your totem as been
that way you know we met lizard form or
in that snake form or in that bird full
or in that waterfall. You've been there.
You've been through that way before.
Nothing has changed. It's no surprise
that people.
Live before they've been there before.
There's the dreaming stories like i
was saying with the bagel people
and with an important people and that's
still occurring that still happening.
And there is a there's a happy ending.
There's a happy ending to it.
If people. People want to learn the culture
and they want to learn the language.
Now the language.
In the nimbin area
and up in the bungalow an area has been
given the go ahead by the elders to be
taught and they're teaching it.
So the language needs to go out and
when people start learning the language
of the land the indigenous language.
They then automatically
have a deed to the land
as far as their standing.
Of that land you speak the language.
You're banjo in which you're speaking
the language you're speaking bundle
and which.
And you learning the language learning the
dreaming learning the significance of
the language because the language gives
specific references to the sacred
places and what they mean i can talk
and explain things in english
and to my face goes blue
but unless the if you learn bungalow
then i talk to you when bhonsle
or the elders are talking to you in mind
and then you get the full
import of one word what
the other inferences are on the spirit level
on the earth level in the water level
and all of these things so
that gives to a sort of like a deed of.
Sharing the land.
They're called no longer which is
ours then it becomes ours not yours
and mine which is the
situation that exists now.
And it's very important
to learn the language.
So people listening to
this talk or whatever
that if they can make an effort to
learn the language of their local area
and to approach kori people in the
elders for that and and to get
that culture
and language happening within their
communities as it is up here in the bundle
and there won't be as much confusion about
land rights because that comes from the
rights of the land the land has rights.
These are the lands rights.
People the human beings the
human dreaming is to maintain.
And to respect the laws of the
land and the rights of the land
and if people don't enforce or if
they show a lack of interest in.
The land's rights. Well we all die.
That's as simple as
that because the land is the law
and no human being is greater
than the law go back to mention.
People going to. Think. As.
Well there was a tradition
of people coming from.
Far
and wide from the far reaches of this
continent come into nimbin for giving given
that ability to fly. Now people can
interpret others all sorts of things a is
that a physical is a yogic process that
they're talking about when there's a fly.
Well yes we all people did
physically move through the air
but that was a time back then.
That was a time back then there's different
ways to move through the air now
without having to bounce up
and down on your pointy
like t m. Sorry motion.
But you know like there's other ways.
There's other means to fly through the air.
I mean people can do that
physically now anyway. Through.
You know planes or through. Flying a kite.
Or whatever you know doing stuff
like that. I mean that's there.
People can ab-soul down the rock.
You know. And so on and so on.
That's done physically.
What was on the other.
Rainforest you.
Better see we're talking
about this 200 year period
when.
The old people had no need as such for
specific people to take care of their
healing and to have responsibility for.
Someone else's health. I mean that
that was everyone's responsibility for
their own health in the way and the way
that it was
that the old people led their
lifestyle anyway excluded sickness
and so on and if people did come
down with a sickness is that they.
You know there was family. Remedies.
Plant knowledge where they can just go
and fix themselves up by feeling
a little bit out of sorts.
Or stuff of nothing major.
But within the still want to do
your period because of the sickness
that did come to this land there were people
who were specialised you had to become
specialised. And so like i'm saying
with this martial law business.
You know there were people who specifically
became warriors people specifically
were designated we and some who civically
there's an added other other tasks.
Because like i said it was.
Oppressive times and people were
concerned with just surviving.
So there were people who who were given
the tasks of being custodians of certain
ologies so on
and so on because the majority of our
people were concerned with with surviving.
With with hiding and running.
So it's it's a tradition
that smallest was been amplified over the
last hundred years where certain people
were given a training for healing.
So the story. Has a happy ending.
How do you think why you think you. I.
Strong faith in them and where people in
them and will. Well they already have.
I mean there's attrition o
that in the last 20 years with people
are exploring alternative healing.
Alternative thinking and methods for 30
powers and and so on so on. You know.
So that's a happy story.
Same as it was the same as this in the
dreaming story where the people were taken.
Who are outcasts basically from.
The invading people and they were
taken by an inborn up to nimbin
and they were taught
medicine and toward healing.
To take back down to their people.
And say good law you know given
sacred or in things like
that to to take to their
people to heal to fix them.
You know to say that you know
it's going to be all right.
You know like don't panic
and the human spirit is.
The most resilient thing
in the universe in place
yet as good. Again.